Diablo and talking to you I always  sensed a ashby Diablo connection really  that's wonderful what was what was the  thing that hooks you enter in to harold  and maude the first time I saw Harold  motto is probably 14 and I have to say  at that time I had not seen and I hate  to play the vcard here but I'm like the  only lady up here and I feel like I had  to see the character of mod who was  though she was the love interest she was  the female lead and she was in her 80s  and she sparkled and was presented with  such affection it was I was just  intoxicated I just saw a whole new world  of characters in my mind and that I no  longer had to kind of fixate on the you  know the stock this or the stock that or  the girlfriend like Maude was amazing to  me  you